Mikoyan congratulations on your
engagement now you're going to be the
best Queen auradon has ever seen it's a
new chapter for auradon and the Isle of
the Lost
you and Ben will be so happy together
but we want to know what happens next
what is your wedding going to be like
what happens to Carlos we have so many
questions and we want answers
descendants three was epic but we
already want more if there was a
descendant for a movie what would it be
about keep watching for some fan
theories that make total sense the Royal
Wedding
move over William and Kate step aside
Harry and Megan there is only one Royal
Wedding that we really care about
we want to see Malin then get married we
want to see the wedding gown that Evy
designs and we definitely want to know
who Mouse bridesmaids will be Eevee is
obviously her maid of honor but do you
think Emma and Jane will be her
bridesmaids and let's be honest we
definitely want to see the moment that
mal officially becomes queen of auradon
and the aisle some fans have suggested
that descendants four could open with a
royal wedding others have suggested that
Disney Channel could release a short
film of just the wedding we wonder if
Maleficent would come now would have to
turn her back into a human since we're
pretty sure she's still a lizard the new
vks descendants 3 brought four new
villain kids to auradon those were dizzy
Tremaine Celia facili a and squeaky and
squirmy Smee the poor four have moved on
from their time at a word on prep
descendants four could focus on these
four new VKS
Celia is definitely the ringleader and
dizzy is going to bring a whole new
level of fashion to the school we would
love to see more about these characters
plus the barrier is now permanently open
auradon prep will get a lot more V Ches
it would be awesome to see how auradon
prep changes with all the new kids it
will have new challenges and new
adventures that the original Ford didn't
have honestly a movie about Celia and
dizzy would be absolutely amazing
the next generation here's another
popular theory for descendants floor
what if the movie takes place in the
distant future we could see the kids of
mal and Ben who would be Prince and
princesses it would be fun to see if
they are tough like mal or kind like
been growing up with Hades as your
grandpa would be a blast
Doug and Easy's kids would be the
perfect combination of smart and stylish
Evie would have upgraded from her
starter castle to a really nice one
their kids would be BFFs with Mouse
children we could find out if Jay ends
up with Lonnie or not will oh my get
married and have kids or will she be the
cool aunt to Mouse family and will Harry
and Audrey end up together their kids
would be the perfect antagonist in
descendants for hopefully they would
learn how to be good just like their
parents did what about Carlos the whole
world was devastated with the loss of
Cameron boys he was definitely taken too
soon if Disney ever made a descendants
for it they would have to address the
fact that Carlos is gone it wouldn't be
fair to just recast him so what happens
to Carlos the most obvious way to
explain his absence is actually
mentioned in descendants 3 he says that
his mom Cruella will be really
disappointed when she finds out that he
wants to be a vet he could be off that
veterinarian school it takes a long time
to become a vet you have to get your
bachelor's degree first which takes 4 to
5 years and then that school is another
4 years that's at least eight years that
Carlos will have to be away from Oregon
he could also go off to rescue animals
after vet school - in our hearts
Carlos is forever so we would love for
descendants forward to mention Carlos
and Jane throughout the film life with
the villains now that the barrier is
open forever there
a whole new set of issues magic will now
work on the Isle of the Lost and the
villains who were imprisoned there can
come to auradon that is going to cause
some serious conflict king ben and queen
mal definitely have their work cut out
for them so maybe all the villains
aren't that bad a tease just wants to be
God at the underworld again he really
came through for mal and
auradon at the end so we won't have to
worry about him dr. casselli a is a
really great dad we think his love for
Celia will keep him honest but what
about the rest of the villains gorilla
deville and Maleficent are not nice
people and we never met some of the
villains like Captain Hook and Ursula we
have a hard time believing that they'll
all decide to behave since banishing and
imprisoning people on the Isle isn't an
option anymore Ben and mal will have to
find other ways to keep the people of
auradon saved maybe they'll make a
rehabilitation centre for the villains
who are having a hard time being good it
would be so cool to see how auradon and
the Isle mesh together in the brand new
world Ben and mal have created so what
do you guys think is the story really
over and what would you want to see in
descendants forward tell us in the
comments thank you for watching be sure
to like this video and subscribe to the
things for more awesome content
[Music]